alright let's talk about weed I thought
this was interesting California Governor
Jerry Brown was on Meet the Press and
even though we've got a great amount of
momentum behind legalization he's not
totally for it let's take a look I forty
years ago we weren't talking about
legalizing marijuana and States either
is that a good idea or a bad idea for
California well we have medical
marijuana which gets very close to what
they have in Colorado in Washington I
really like those two states to show us
how it's going to work the problem with
anything a certain amount is okay but
there is a tendency to go to extremes
and all of a sudden if there's
advertising and legitimacy how many
people can get stoned and still have a
great state or a great nation world's
pretty dangerous very competitive I
think we need to stay alert if not 24
hours a day more than some of the pot
heads might be able to put together yes
the world is very dangerous and
obviously if you legalize weed the guys
in charge of the nukes are going to be
stoned of course what while he was being
an argument that would explain it
actually but wait so he talked about the
advertising so the first commercial for
marijuana has come out and let's take a
look at a bit of that yo you want sushi
I got sushi I got the best sushi this
area is driving and you know that I know
that and nobody's telling but me I got
tuna I got salmon I got sweet shrimp I
got the finest sesame this area has seen
in years
you need me and I need you let's make
this work you buy some sashimi I'll
throw in some rice paper man totally
freaked Brett dude I got everything even
California rolls baby you wouldn't buy
your sushi from this guy so why would
you buy your marijuana from him
marijuana doctors calm is the only
service that connects patients with real
doctors from medical marijuana
recommendations simple confidential safe
okay clearly a very powerful commercial
I just want to say in defense of the
guys that deal weed I've bought a lot of
weed in my day from a bunch of different
people I've never had a weed guy have
any of you bought weed and had the weed
guy been like and here's crack right let
go like this appears everything else I
got heroin over here a memo to you the
week I sells weed it's the other drug
I think generally right is that oh he's
another drug dealer right he can like
kick you up the chain probably but like
but he's not it you know he's just some
NYU kid who's like trying to yeah I
think that's like almost like the the
problem with the you know lumping people
who do stand up what monologist with
prop comics very different genre is pot
and the other stuff is it's a different
market it's just a different market so
in the eyes of the stand up pure stand
ups we're the weed right we're the one
that's okay that's I like to think I'm
probably not mix that's like well that's
like that's math you start one day you
go down that road for carrot top I just
think what my points is is if it's a
whole different genre and people always
to their you know because they want to
make a sale they're lumping them
together yeah so I don't wanna get too
hung up on the commercial but one thing
I think is interesting is that now that
we have commercials for wheat isn't it
interesting that they immediately went
to the fear angle like so marketing is
so based in fear because nothing about
there's nothing scary about weed every
study proves that and yet for the first
commercial they immediately went to
something awful tell you about what does
that tell you about marketing and
advertising even for weed come on it
means weeds gone mainstream like no no
we to sell to us the same way that
prescription medicine is sold to us
which is actually much more dangerous in
a lot of cases I mean if you if you're
gonna give leave if weed was advertised
like in most prescription medicine and
you know at the end they have to do that
you know fast speaking disclaimer which
it seems the a year after year gets
longer and like a bigger percentage of
the commercial suicide vomiting extra
you can hear what they're saying exactly
and so what would the weed would be like
you'll get hungry occasionally you'll be
a little paranoid may watch 10 episodes
of house of cards in a row like that's
I'll take my chances with those side
effects yeah every study shows that
alcohol is just as if not more dangerous
than worried what what we're thinking
that nobody who
their hand on the nuke is an alcoholic
nobody who nobody who's in government is
an alcoholic like glaringly obvious to
the one we see there were plenty of
people who have alcohol trade out down
in Florida just two months ago caught
buying coke he was a congressman down
exactly and we weed has if I found out
that Barack Obama was still in the
shooting gang or whatever he I think
that's what he called it when he was a
kid if he was still smoking weed every
day I would not be like oh my stars like
huh no more so than when I find out like
he's having a beer summit with somebody
right damn beer summit yeah go back to
Jerry Brown's just right what you said I
mean that he was saying that he didn't
wouldn't think it would be a good idea
because people would go overboard
basically that definitely should he
should talk about alcohol I mean why is
that okay to sell that and people
clearly abuse alcohol yeah and we just I
mean marijuana is nowhere near and it's
harmful what it so someone like Jerry
Brown who is the governor of the state
we have it it's basically legal here I
think almost recreationally at least in
LA I mean anyone can get weed at any
time there's no evidence that crime is
going up finally they can tax it in it
actually there so there are benefits to
the state it seems because he just
completely out of touch or is he what
base is he playing that's what that's
what I understand in California who is
he playing Bobby there's some kind of
Lobby because if he really believed what
he was saying
then then alcohol would not be as widely
available yeah I think your is a great
point that they it is basically legal a
weed doctor in LA is is a joke of a
doctor I when I I have a marijuana card
when I went to go to the you know
consultation or whatever the woman tried
to upsell me Botox in she was you know I
I get migraines occasionally that was my
reason for getting a weed card yeah I
mean legitimate is it what kind of boat
but so she said she's like well you know
you get migraines I can clear that up
with a little Botox here and a little
Botox here $145 a shot I can do it right
here right now I like it and it's like
okay this is better than being able to
walk into a store and
meet my like friendly neighborhood
Claire can be like yes sir I would just
like I have to go through the Botox lady
like it's funny it also goes against my
initial thought was which was that the
weed guys only sell you weed now that
it's getting legalized the weed people
are also selling you boats it is
basically legal here it's to act like
it's not is medically any of these
storefront doctors who advertise like
whatever you pay $70 you tell them you
get anxious
where's in Colorado you don't have to go
to the doctor you can just go to the
store yeah so okay so if his angle is
that there's got to be some lobby or
something but what what is the fear
factor with him I don't understand was
someone like him I assume he believes in
science and studies so I don't get what
the other piece of this is like what the
piece that says suddenly if it's legal
everyone's gonna become a pothead and as
a nation we're gonna become dumber
because I don't think there's even any
reason to believe that more people are
gonna start smoking weed necessary no
one now doesn't smoke weed because right
yeah yeah I have no idea what I mean
there's something that there's something
going on something there were some
conversations going on behind that he's
not copping to because that's ridiculous
especially who you know he used to be I
mean you know yeah he grows and
everybody changes but other ways to grow
the other way what more liberal yeah but
I guess people don't but III think that
he's definitely out of touch
he's definitely he at least that's what
he sounds like I think the real simple
fact is that nobody has ever gotten
kicked out of office for seeming
anti-drug like that's it's a really easy
cheap way to make a point it's not he's
not gonna lose any you know he's not
gonna lose votes by saying it and the
fact of the matter is like that horse
has left the bar and here already so he
can get on TV and say you know like oh
you know we don't want too much pot in
this country like it's gonna be
dangerous and meanwhile all his
constituents can tweet if they want it
and he
it's to look like he's a strong on drugs
tough on crime you know yeah all right
well I'm pretty sure it's just gonna go
down the same way gay marriage has gone
down which is just gonna be state by
state by state I guess it's gonna take a
little longer in California than we
might have thought